youtuber house tours we're back again
are we gonna find an s tier youtuber
house store probably not because i am
extremely
overly critical for no reason but
entertainment yeah today we have some
good ones we have big star ryland
there's no house in this video
apparently uh connersy dog
and uh random couple i don't know who
they are let's frickin do this which one
do we start with big star yeah
oh yeah number one on trending all right
let's go welcome to our brand new home
yo the fireplace at the entrance let's
go
what a smashing villa may
look at that
fry
i don't know what to say what am i
looking at where do you put your code
i'm just trying to figure out the layout
so in a minute we can take a look
a newly constructed house bit of a blank
canvas what do you think yeah
uh okay so uk house market
like you probably have to pay at least
at least 30
minimum
more uh to get the same kind of quality
that not quality but you know luxury uh
that you get in the states for example i
i think at least so as you come into the
house yeah you come in where i put shoes
you have the hallway which is oh no i
hate that glass thing
i think i know the artist
i'm sorry but dude
it's okay it actually kind of suits the
house but i hate that type of last [ __ ]
so tall
because i think they were doing an
exhibit where me and marcia had our
wedding uh and the art is like oh that
that's copyrighted so uh you can't take
any photos we're like we didn't ask for
your [ __ ] glass to be in our photos
okay so annoying like we rented this
venue months ago and then they're like
oh there's a glass exhibit now but you
can't take any photos i'm like get your
glass shipped out of our wedding
it's hot they look just like that
ceilings and then it's it's two-story so
it's wild i love the staircase the way
it goes out we've got a little a little
honestly that uh that looks like a
smashing epic time to slide down that
staircase or although will you break the
glass that is the question fire in here
too
that is actually doubles up as uh like
an air humidifier and yeah oh that's
sick
now i like it i guess it's kind of close
to have a fireplace as soon as you enter
but this is such a guy there isn't it
like evil bond villain i like this line
what's that it's so it's it's it's a
hallway i don't know what else to say
but we'll bring you one through to the
rest of the house as you guys know i
love open plan living you've probably
seen from the flats i've been in so this
is the
kitchen slash kind of casual living area
um we come around here the kitchen is
massive
i i like vickstar i don't want to be me
but what the hell am i looking at
it's so great i can't even tell
like what is what he's got the blind
fridge very nice i like the layout
i like the layout open spline space
uk has finally caught up that open plan
space is actually a thing it could do a
lot a hundred years later in here not
that i will be maybe i should learn
maybe i should learn one thing that i
think
that you know what they should do they
should do all these new k kitchen for
houses just like give them like a
delivery wrap wall or something instead
no one's gonna cook in these kitchens
deliverers take care why is that
smashing glass did you break already we
got this
this cracked glass backsplash i assume
that was intentional
no
no no [ __ ] way that's intentional i
don't think someone just dropped this on
the way in i think no that is not
intentional are you kidding me it's
meant to look like that but it's a bit
different from the humorous sounded
brokenness
i broke my uh
outdoor glass window and it looked
identical like this and i i don't know
if that's a desirable effect the kitchen
also has a few secrets i don't know if
any of you have spotted them yet the
first one is right here you think it's a
cupboard it's actually more than it
comes it's uh
whoa so much storage that's so smart so
it's a ladder that's i can you can there
we go okay that's sick again you might
think it's a cupboard but in actual fact
we have a
room that's kind of cool
what the [ __ ] so now that there's some
stuff i like i can say uh what the [ __ ]
what's with all the gray i hate this
countertop the [ __ ] is this light do it
you want to drag over any color in there
big store but though that's sick you can
hit him you might think it's a cupboard
but in actual fact
we have a utility room and while we're
here in the secret utility we also have
we have that exact bag
i don't know why and in here we have
the ferrex v11 4.8 liter
lawnmower this thing is serious this
thing is mean oh
not electric [ __ ]
and that's just ah come on get that [ __ ]
out of the way the background uh my
tesla is i still have that that is out
and about on its travel somewhere but
let's go and take a look inside this one
right here what does that mean no no no
we're doing house not [ __ ]
this side connected to the uh kitchen
counter so the first like living room in
kitchen is just like this long room it's
kind of cozy in a way and i like the
i mean i
hate the furniture not to lie but i do
like the layout
of it it's kind of cool with like the
fireplace being open space so you've got
this
it's like almost tacky i think the
furniture makes it low but
it's still cool because i i think it's
so cool we got the tv up here floating
now this is so what's the plan behind
there then because that's all empty like
what would you put there would be like a
game
dining table one thing we've been doing
yeah debating do we leave this white or
do we get some sort of some sort of
wallpaper design on here let me know in
the comments section uh that's the first
question we have enough
you can leave it white although some
kind of color would be nice i'm not a
fan of whole foods fireplace here as
well
and then
is that that's a fake
that's a fake fireplace but damn look at
the effects on they come around they got
a good one look at that you see the
other side we have an empty space
yeah an empty space what are you gonna
do with it right underneath the
chandelier you have a nice circular
table here maybe even one of the ones
i've seen them where you can like twist
them and expand out another little bit
of clever storage right here you've uh
got this i guess you could put um
drinks and bits and bobs in here i don't
know but it's just another useful space
and another feature that we have in here
is if you look up how awesome is that
it's just those little extra touches
that why not why not right extend
yeah
pretty common in the uk
yeah so then as we come out of the
dining area i guess we have the living
okay so
you enter like on the other left side of
where he is right now
right did i understand the layout yeah
living room which again and that's where
the living room is it's very empty right
now but it's it's a living room what is
that to say have you got any cool ideas
for it let us know i'm definitely not
doing this video just to steal ideas
from you guys of what to do with the
house
those lights the those lights they what
you gonna do with those lights
it's got a very masculine the whole this
whole black marble or stone or whatever
it is uh tone to it kind of suits him i
just personally am not like that's not
what i would go for he's got a pool
pool in uk is such a like is it worth it
like you see the weather great that's
that's 99 percent of the time that's how
it looks like you really need a pool in
uk this is the question i mean tonight
uh the english weather yeah
there you go there you go we're helpful
with that yeah here it is
here we have outdoor shower and the hot
tub
and then round here we have the barbecue
area again gonna have to pray for some
good weather yeah exactly like you're
not gonna get good use out of that it's
like uh uk is just adopting all this
like l.a kind of style of things and
it's like okay i guess that's not in a
great way right now but there is there
is a koi car
pond don't have any koi carp don't
really know if i want any koi carp but
yeah it's a koi kopp pond
nice
we're ticking all the unnecessary rich
people [ __ ]
i love it
[Music]
whoa we went under
yeah
for a moment i was like how did you do
that he said okay i'm dumb sorry
we have the master bathroom which is is
yeah there you go that's stone again
like brock come on
a lot of closet space well right now
that's nice yeah two things what are
they this is slidy angle shelves angle
shelves i don't know what i'm doing
yeah that's pretty nice good for you
vickstar good for you
i think i'm so oh [ __ ] that's so cozy
what a great idea
they should really be uh homes not the
the shape of the room doesn't suit a
home cinema but i mean
real gaming quarters we have a whole
cinema room got the bar in the back for
anyone that wants drinks
big sofa for all the guests i'd love to
kick back and watch something now but
i'm a busy guy and i've got more of this
house to show you so
[ __ ] big is this house jesus an
awesome gym
on the top floor really let's assume
it's in the basement or something but
yeah fair enough cool good for you good
for you big star you got your own tv the
mirror is already set up has like a
little kitchen area as well i actually
really like this but the red is so bad
their ice looks kind of cool i've had
some snacks take over to the cinema room
a post-workout treat you can do that
here as well
we even ha
i'm so [ __ ] jealous
bro i have i have so much money
but i'm here because i am waiting to
move and it's so frustrating
and then another promise i would never
buy a house like this because just like
why
what is wrong with me i'm jealous but i
could get it but i don't want it what
the [ __ ] oh and it's up nice
i'll give you that big star it lights up
really cozy i guess i gotta read this
for uk i would say
you know not bad
i don't know how to
like rate it because like i've been so
harsh on all of them it's definitely
better than facebook i think it's close
yeah
yeah let's go with that spreading the
face rug that makes me think i should
put him here but i hated his house
moving on let's check out rylan crazy
he's coming back i can tell he's coming
back soon
we're moving right or i don't know what
do you want to do
i don't know we could honestly so didn't
they already buy a farm and now i think
they bought another one and i'm just
very confused
i can't get rid of our house
so like this house is less than half the
price of our greenhouse less than half
how is that possible same square footage
less rooms look at the view of the
postmates
so this one cost half as much as our
other one that's interesting
that's kind of cute on the outside it's
got some character
yeah
it's cozy
in this house we laugh a lot we kind of
dude i would i really alright done not
this house is not for me [ __ ] this
oh gosh
okay clearly an interior decorator has
done something for this i still don't
like it
oh this is the kitchen
it's got some character to it like the
ceiling being uh
wooden panels or
you know what the white right now i'm
not sold on this tile though but it's
kind of quirky
oh my god
they have knickknacks they have
i don't know what i'm looking at it just
looks fancy
i like those fireplaces it's kind of
cool kind of odd place for it but
down there there's more
a basement under the basement
oh this is so cool office was on your
checklist
yeah this is a shane office oh my gosh
i like the surroundings probably more
than anything it looks like very remote
relaxing
no one wants around i would probably
prefer a house like located like this i
think that's really nice i'm not sold on
the house itself but
yeah i like how remote it is and the
tour is so badly filmed i don't feel
like going through it but it looks all
right take a seat yeah sure
i'm feeling more generously sure
sure okay i don't know who the hell
these people are so i can say whatever i
want hey everyone
we have an incredible episode for you
today so you join me in knoll in
solihull summer and i are going to be
exploring this looks like vikksar's
house on the outside dude
so okay they they're just doing
walkthroughs of other people's houses
every new building in uk looks like this
the white and the black they finally
realize like the white [ __ ] whatever
plastic it is they use on windows that's
blasted on every house in the uk it's
like no now we do black and it's all
white and this is how house looking at
this is gonna be dated so fast dude
people are gonna be sick of this i would
never buy a house like this trust me
this incredible they look like new
modern sleek so cool dude the price
have dropped like crazy because they're
badly behind me full of innovation full
of technology yeah let's see it okay
let's see
i love this toast bro did they forget to
remove the tape on the door what is that
that's so ugly come on come on get that
[ __ ] away from me
and i love the led lights on both sides
and this
wow whatever you want what would you use
it wow what a cool room i love to sit
there and watch on my last but this
place was smaller than my [ __ ]
tv i mean my display
the random mirror and the random what is
this
and the base in the corner
before yeah i mean
it's a separate lounge
i love this room
i would love to sit in this room and i
feel so good about my purchases
[Laughter]
an older family hey grandpa you sit in
this and you look at your tv and your
face's corner
lovely large windows to that side with
electric blinds yeah whoa underfloor
heating throughout as well and of course
the uk obligatory got to put those
lights in everywhere how many how many
but it's at 12 in total probably behind
me nah more we need 10 more underfloor
heating throughout and in uk they love
putting carpeting and i never understand
why because it's kind of nasty they get
really really dirty all three floors
it's concrete and another weird thing is
people walk in with their shoes on those
carpets which is even more like
what what are you doing
um with let's see if he has his shoes on
i'm generally curious now first floor
and second floor is all carpet as well
that's a shoe reveal
okay he took off his shoes bless him
sorry let's pop the floor plan up on the
screen yes no
don't care it has a disability ah what
the [ __ ] is that tile dude
dude i got it i i what the [ __ ] is this
ugly i've ever seen jesus christ dude
everything about this is ugly this tile
sucks this whole thing sucks that sucks
it sucks red towels okay red theme in
the thing who would go for a red theme
huh that's [ __ ] cringe
yeah grandpa here's your shower idiot oh
god it just hurts to look good
i can feel the floor heating i think i
know
so tacky
i bet you this is like three million or
some dumb [ __ ] like what oh god a
section over here oh god it's hit it's
so bad it's so bad it's so ugly it's so
ugly
who made this kind of like the lights
though they're kind of cool what the
[ __ ]
liberally made slightly offset this is
the worst
yeah like anyone's ever gonna sit there
shut up
why would anyone sit there why explain
to me the process of people sitting here
and then be like all right
hey how you doing lately they take a
seat down there over there
how we
[ __ ] slightly off center to allow
some room over here for sitting
reading
reading actually you've got the main
reading right here listen i understand
these are like placeholder furniture
that would just put in really cheaply to
fill the space but man you have to put
in a little bit more
come on
i would definitely have a nap oh
yeah i would rather see the place empty
than put in a bunch of furniture that i
hate
that's what controls
well now i know how the ugliest version
of it would ever be
i like the backyard that's nice a lot of
space it looks private no one can see it
i like that
private golf course now where i don't
see the carpet
you can tear down that shed and build a
like an i don't know like an outdoor
office a lot of people do that in uk
those chairs those chairs is kind of
like you find at the shittiest pub in
your years of [ __ ]
points out some more details so for
example down here these skirting boards
now these are around 100 mil high which
is higher than and they're already been
dented dude look at them how is that
even [ __ ] possible what you normally
find in a new property like this and
it's just little details that you start
to see like that and really set this
place apart
and so this is the dining room it's more
of a formal space now whilst you've got
i it hurts my soul to just look at this
what the [ __ ] am i looking at a random
chair corner
most of your time
um as the owners pointed out it is still
nice to have a dining area for christmas
time
family get-togethers and obviously
different yeah yeah sure sure why is
there like electric sockets here what
are you gonna like what are you gonna
put there i guess if you put a cupboard
there or something actually and then a
light on top never mind retract
statement you'll notice these large
windows these are like the biggest
windows that they could find and these
are throughout the whole house
and they there are definitely bigger
windows than that get it out of here
okay kitchen
and throughout the year looks amazing
yeah and that's been completely polished
so yeah it looks really nice so now okay
across here we've got the samsung ovens
this is actually a double oven so you
can open it all the way we have 600
ovens
these charging points that pop out
if i can remember how they actually do
that there we go
yeah
each side of the island
i kind of like that they put on the side
in a weird way
because it's kind of awkward
i don't know okay i'm just going to
assume i hate the red i hate it i hate
it so much this is the the ugliest thing
i've ever seen i wonder how much it goes
for it says there three million i'm so
stupid oh my god it's literally a right
move i told you bro they're so bad
it's not even worth buying a property
here because this is the [ __ ] yeah
imagine making it right all your dreams
come true you made all that money you
got that big money and this is what you
[ __ ] get
cool
that's awesome love this
what the [ __ ] what's the point it's just
depressing me or is it located that'd be
birmingham
unbelievable what are people saying
looks like they're 16 year old decorated
from an elvis presley yard sale
thank god it's not just me i'd have to
change all the doors yeah right hasn't
this house been on the market for nearly
three years now for that prize and
interior design no wonder is struggling
to sell oh thank god i'm not crazy holy
[ __ ] all right connor connor c-dog
made a house tour welcome to the house
tour there's probably going to be a
little theme to this maybe you can
figure it out anyway let's start with my
front door unfortunately today oh wait i
forgot to rate the other one it's not a
youtuber house tour i know i know
whatever i'm actually you know what
i'm doing it i never thought i'd find an
equally bad one done all right i don't
have a cameraman to help me so this is
all gonna be me this is my
front door area the coca-cola flip-flops
that i want you definitely didn't clean
up before the video did you
conor how long have you lived in japan
literally anytime anyone japanese come
and visit what they do is they'll put
their chair they'll put their uh shoes
like that neatly as they could and they
even angle them so that once they leave
they can come back and they're angled
the right way i don't know what i'm
saying this is awful now you're thinking
connor uh why don't you put the shoes
in the shoe drawer yeah that's
a pretty fair question yeah much sense
so i don't do that does it just work
i keep my masks my cute little masks
nice and organized yeah it looks great
and stuff and hats and whatever anything
that goes out often and doesn't mean
that is a winter jacket is it summer
right now
in any specific place just kind of goes
here and now
my bathroom hello hey we're jumping
straight in hey welcome to my house
bathroom here you go
don't judge that yeah i mean this is
just the bathroom kind of basic
all right he said don't judge it so i'm
not gonna
it's a bathroom what do you want it's a
bathroom
over here we have a laundry machine now
note this is not the
super cheap one that i got for free on
craigslist oh yeah these these japanese
style washers are so much better because
if you forget to put an item in you can
literally just open the lid and put more
stuff in and i know that's the thing in
american drive thing but we don't have
that in europe okay it's cool to me uh
the one that had cockroaches i got a new
one and right here this is where i just
hang up my towels and stuff whatever you
get it alright let me show you the bath
check this out all right
whoa that's a nice bath huh it's a brown
bat i don't know who wants a brown bat
that seems kind of psychotic it
that's a serial killer bathtub right
there ah this is like a
why didn't you not remove that
wow by a while i mean a few months as
you can see uh this is like a filter for
like
the cooking stuffs that goes up it's
very dirty right now because i haven't
actually cleaned anything this is oh
you're supposed to put it up oh my god
i used to use a kettle but then when i'm
streaming i just want the water to come
out instantly and i want it to be
boiling so this just keeps it boiling
all the time it's it's a kitchen oh my
god i don't use any of this [ __ ] you
know i mean i occasionally i clean but
clearly i haven't this is my fridge but
it doesn't have cockroaches in it isn't
it amazing this time i got a fridge with
no cockroaches so when i got my old
fridge uh it had cockroaches in if you
didn't know um because i got it from
somebody on craigslist we've got not
much going on in this fridge
it's uh this kind of i noticed that when
pewdiepie did a house tour video ah
shout out i actually have a wine fridge
too
it's so convenient you can put like
drinks in here and it keeps them at like
room hell yeah i just love
wine fridges are clearly made for like
who drinks wine anyway come on get the
[ __ ] out of here it's for gamers to have
their game or drinks and that's it and
connor please clean that
up i want then when i'm coming to japan
connor i'm i'm heading straight to your
flat and i'm cleaning up we're going to
do a big clear up we're going to do hey
this how about this you need this no
don't even answer we're throwing that
out for all my problems we're gonna
throw all this [ __ ] out we're throwing
this out this uh this uh down here that
comes out like this that's too lazy and
i haven't had time to fill it up but by
time i mean i'm just i'm just lazy i'm
so lazy oh boy
so that's my kitchen i don't really use
it much no um i should be using it more
but i don't this is my living room it's
a mess right now it was much more of a
mess before i started filming this i've
actually have another room here which
i've never used you're telling me you
cleaned before this
so okay the whole story about when i
moved here right
this looks like a torture room doesn't
it
how depressing is this
it's a random chair
and it's also a weird shape like look at
this yeah what the [ __ ] what do you do
with that room pentagram on the ground i
guess you could put a desk or some [ __ ]
what this is this is such an awkward
room chair like i don't even put a desk
there but yeah there you go use it i'd
rather not waste it and buy a desk you
know when i moved to japan i couldn't
get a place that would accept me because
i was a foreigner and i didn't live in
japan at the time this struggle was one
that accepted me and the problem with it
is that it has too many rooms that i was
never ever going to use i had no choice
i just wanted a place so [ __ ] dumb
the cheapest dining table set i found on
amazon
this is my old deal do you mean you
don't know where all the chat there was
one in the other room there's one
clearly there oh wait that's the same
rope yeah that's a chair that i don't
use anymore this is a bunch of the crane
game prizes that i won and this is my
couch this was a game with the cheapest
corner couch on amazon had to offer i
think it was like just under 300 bucks
which is crazy and within like 10
minutes of sitting on it it already
started to like sag i don't know if you
can see that it looks like it's kind of
it's not even connected
you can
you deserve a nice comfy sofa connor
come on the reason why the living room
is so messy is i don't really use the
living room much i mainly spend time but
then it shouldn't be messy just clean it
once and never use it always clean
that's like the best scenario ever no
entropy you don't use the come on car
come on god
i guess i think what i'm generally
worried about with go moving to japan is
that it's so complicated to recycle
stuff and and as an average
throw [ __ ] away addicting addictor
addiction that i have how the [ __ ] am i
gonna live do you know how much stuff i
get
like i love this figure but do i need
three of them
no
i don't what he do
you can just give it away okay i guess
i'll go to jet random japanese people
and give stuff away normally this table
right here is extremely messy i just
what is it now then what do you mean
it's normally extremely what is it
dump everything on it and then i clean
it once every two weeks that's kind of
how it goes i don't actually use the
dining table it's more of like a pseudo
storage all right so we go into my
bedroom which is just your entire space
of your flat suits that this description
also if it seems like i'm a harsh car i
i've met carl he's a really cool dude
i'm sure he doesn't mind there's
somebody playing on the other side of
the house and this is gonna be the most
tragic
of 2021.
this is my bedroom
this is literally it yes it's just this
i love that i love the tv next to the
bed
there's another one of your chairs we
found it
oh yeah
i brought one of the very small
dining uh
dining set chairs and i used that as a
tv stand up there
2.2 million subscribers on youtube and i
definitely live like one this is the
tatami room and this is where i filmed
the cosplay video yeah i've seen these
okay i clearly misunderstood this whole
video i thought this was his new place
and he's already made it so messy that
makes no sense uh
and he's moving out of this he's doing
the pokemon when i moved in here i
thought this was going to be a
completely useless room but i'm really
glad that i got to use it in some videos
because it is actually a really cool
room like it's funny our place in japan
has tatami room too and we just asked to
take them out and i don't know if that's
culturally insensitive or something i
just don't see us using it i i'm i
okay his setup looks pretty
all right i like the art especially he's
a man of culture obviously jojo stan i
can't tell if like i'm
everyone else is normal and i'm crazy
he's like i hate having stuff it i hate
having stuff
i hate it
i don't like having stuff i hate having
stuff it makes me feel anxious because
it feels like i'm bound to all these
things like if they just feel like a
responsibility some like a loose end
that i have to deal with at some point
the less stuff i have the more free i
feel and i know that it probably doesn't
make sense it just makes me feel anxious
and i don't know what the right opinion
is maybe it's better to have a lot of
stuff
i don't know is it weird i only met
carter once but i do want to i do hope
he invites me over and we can build
furniture together it's got some nice
new furniture nice good for him
okay connor smaller
i think
phase rug is just the new threshold and
this is obviously better than faze rug
it's better than cara delevingne i think
we got a nest here there we go thank you
for watching this video if you enjoyed
smash like subscribe i realize i don't
have enough subscribers so if you can
hit the subscribe button that would help
me out a lot thank you see you tomorrow
breakfast
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator
add some of our patented stickers in
there stickers our emotions memes our
emotions express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this